il est l'heure de répondre à cette
question existentielle celle qu'on se
pose tous chaque semaine sommes-nous t
bills
la réponse est oui mais dans le doute va
quand même faire un petit est savoir si
on est débile ou pas je pense que le
test est plus habile que d'où d'ailleurs
c'est parti ayew tout monté ce coup ci
je sais que ça vous stresse un peu des
fois première question veux tu faire ce
quiz non c'est mon ami qui m'a dit de
faire oui je sais pas et je m'en bats
les steaks
on veut le faire on voit la réponse à
cette question existentielle 2 x 2 égale
qu'à deux ça veut dire quoi fois fort
qui ne sait pas répondre à sa c4 beach
quel président était thomass edison 7 17
3 7 32 et une corrélation il ya une
corrélation c'est sur 2 4 6 8 6 tous
plus de 7 6 9
tiens patineuse dans la liste merde 7
quelle est la bonne prononciation des
hawks irib au nucléaire usagé occire et
boyoud clinton à un test pour savoir si
ce lexique ou quoi ça question piège des
eaux xi ribonucléique gouaillard poyer
beaucoup trop long au des aubes série
hbo nucléaires usés ex trop longue durée
le nom d'un vaccin contre une grave
maladie et uccle et y qu i qu'ultra
question piège question de planètes dans
le bon ordre de la plus proche du soleil
à la plus éloignée
je suis désormais mère dans tout ce qui
est ce pas ce bon déjà les trois ou
quatre sont probablement à chaque fois
les mêmes ouais c'est ça mercure vénus
terre mars
ok ensuite c'est quoi ensuite on a le
choix entre jupiter ou alors as
théorique belt gens c'est tellement rien
en gros nez lui un astéroïde est une où
ça passe directe à jupiter
ok je vais appeler un ami jean-pierre
est ce que c'est votre dernier mot oui
est ce que c'est votre dernier
ok cyprien je suis avec jean pierre
foucault vous n'avez que 30 secondes
pour répondre à une question vous êtes
prêts je dois donner des planètes dans
l'ordre de la plus proche à la plus
éloignée du soleil soit c'est mercure et
vénus la terre mars jupiter et saturne
soit c'est mercury vénus la terre mars
et un astéroïde et ensuite jupiter vous
savez il n'y en a pas ça veut dire
qu'elle est sûre toutefois aussi pris
avec ce quiz est erronée ça va couper
merci cyprien fou qu'on reprend le
dessus est ce que c'est votre dernier
mot a taste pas encore répondu qu on
s'en bat les couilles
tout était faux parmi ces choix là
qu'elle n'est pas une couleur le noir le
bleu le rouge le orange
ça va être compliqué
le noir parce que l'oeil d'einstein sur
cette photo et noir d'affection des
bildt est débile réfection des bills
calais 7 emoji whaou sifflement comptant
ou parkings [ __ ] je suis seul ça y'en
a plein de trous qu'il le savait ce que
j'ai le droit à l'appel à l'abonné est
ce que ces blagueurs boisset ou au
voyage mais ça c'est pour dire au bon
alors ce monde hier tu fais un choix au
cabba mais tout est dans le doute
attention résultats entre les deux on a
répondu à quatre bonnes réponses sur cet
achat / cette fois sans ça fait 57 c'est
marqué juste là je suis débile tu es
intelligent y conte 50 50
[ __ ] ça répond pas à la question
n'aura encore le doute pendant de
longues années on va se console en
faisant un deuxième quiz je peux deviner
si vous êtes une fille ou un garçon on
va voir ça abi tchesa bien je vais vous
poser des questions
choisissez l'une des quatre réponses
quand vous êtes prêt hockey coach oui ok
allez c'est parti
ok ok [ __ ] c'est trop débile c'est
exactement ce que je pense au gros sel
là ok c'est parti première question
quelle est ta couleur préférée
omg c'est la deuxième question pour la
première et ma couleur préférée le bleu
ça c'est une réponse de mecs ça
rose c'est trop évident pour être une
réponse de filles j'aime le bleu le
rouge est une couleur incroyable moi
c'est le bleu de cobalt us m j'aime le
bleu avec qui tu sors le plus souvent
mes meilleures amies mes gars sur ta vu
les gens quelques copains on va mettre
the guys que fais tu de tes week-end les
boutiques des canulars téléphoniques et
des autistes je sors avec mes copains je
sors avec mes amis c'est vrai qu'un
copain n'est pas forcément un ami les
amis sont ceux qu'on aura pendant de
longues années qui seront là pour nous
ce qui répond toujours téléphone peu
importe l'heure à laquelle nous les
appelons et de l'autre côté les copains
sont ceux que l'on voit de temps en
temps avec qui l'on passe du bon temps
ce qui pourrait ac et on compte dofus
honte tu sois vraiment surpris ok je
sors avec mes copains baume qu'est ce
que tu penses du titanic
alex au fait qu'est-ce que je devrais en
pensez c'est un bateau qui a coulé comme
des milliers d'autres il ya des années
quand le mec a aucune émotion quoi c'est
un robot qui a produit cette phrase
c'est zenyatta c'est un film de
gonzesses la réponse d'un bovin
clairement je l' ai vu des millions de
fois et j'ai pleuré à chaque fois ça
peut être un mec comme une fille ça je
pense que c'est un film brillant un peu
bas dans mais ce n'est pas spécialement
vous préférez bombay mémoire d'un film
de gonzesses est maintenant l'heure de
la vie
été peut-il savoir si l'on possède un
pénis ou un vagin seulement grâce à nos
réponses à ce quizz stupide
vous êtes un garçon d'aller aux quêtes
un garçon heureusement le genre de mec
qui ne triche pas qu'il faut qu'une
merde du genre au somment touches je te
dise à du point de vue d'une fille
arrête de faire intéresser alors qu'il
refusera mon invitation au resto peu
importe un aventurier qui aime sortir
messieurs dames nous sommes donc à
moitié intelligent moi tu es stupide
nous sommes bel et bien un homme j'avais
des doutes et la justice en se disant
n'hésitez pas à aller mais ça vous a
plus jamais eu de faire ces deux petits
quizz hyper fidèles précis
révolutionnaire à 2 prochaines vidéos
portez vous bien j'ai tout le monde
glisse